Today for experts in emotion interview.
We have the honor of speaking
with doctor [inaudible] Mehta.
So Dr Mehta is currently an assistant
professor of psychology at the University
of Oregon.
He received his Ba from Williams college
and his phd in social personality
psychology from the University of
Texas at Austin before starting at the
University of Oregon as faculty.
He completed postdoctoral fellowships
at the Columbia University as well as
Erasmus University and the Donders
institute in the Netherlands.
His research examines the psychological
and biological processes that help
regulate status here
arkies and decision making.
So I now turn to a very special experts
in emotion interview together with Dr
[inaudible] Mehta on emotion and hormones
and upcoming and very exciting field.
So welcome prawns. Thanks for
speaking today. Thanks for having me.
It's always a pleasure.
Um,
what I wanted to start out asking a
little bit about is what first got you
interested in emotions?
Well, I think just by nature
of being a person, you know,
we all have emotional
experiences and so we're all,
I think in intrinsically
interested in emotion,
but specific to my work when I'm finding
compelling about emotion is I'm trying
to understand the process. So, um,
how our biology feeds
into the things we do,
how we think, um, and then
how, um, our behaviors and our,
um, in our environments can influence
our biology. And I think that's why,
um, recently I've been really interested
in emotion as kind of the psychological
process by which our biology
piece into our behavior. So,
yeah. Cool. Very cool.
I actually want to ask you then a few
questions about your research in this
domain. So I mean, first of all,
I mean you are so well known already
for your pioneering work that's helped
found this brand new field,
you know,
referred to as social
neuroendocrinology and as a field,
I wondered if you might share with us what
you see as some of the most, you know,
fundamental discoveries thus far
about hormones and social behavior,
etc.
Absolutely.
So I think one of the important things
to recognize is that research item,
uh, hormones and behavior in
humans, it's relatively new.
So a lot of this work on pioneering
work was done in animals.
And so just the fact, uh, over the
past, uh, decade in particular,
there's been a resurgence and research
on an interest in studying, uh,
hormones in social behavior in humans.
So just by nature of doing the work, um,
I think that's pioneering ended up itself.
Um,
but we've also learned a few things.
so a few things that we
do know now is that, um,
there's a, this, this hormone cortisol,
which is released by the HPA axis that
plays a really important role in stress
responses in humans as well as
animals. So we do know that, um,
that's pretty clear.
We also know that, uh,
the steroid hormone
testosterone, which is, uh,
which exists in both men and women,
um,
plays an important role in behaviors
linked to status, such as dominance.
And we're also learning a lot
about oxytocin's role, um,
in social behaviors specifically.
Uh,
it seems to be involved in a
lot of pro social behaviors. Um,
so I think those are the basic
discoveries that we've made and,
but what's really exciting is kind of
the nuance that we're adding as a field.
That these kind of simplistic views
of testosterone, dominance, cortisol,
stress,
oxytocin bonding are being uprooted in
some ways and suggesting that there are
other kind of processes
depending on the context. Um,
and depending on the kind of person
you are that are dictating how these
hormones work. Um, so the fact what
we do and our emotions as well.
So really exciting. I wonder
too, you know, how do you
thank this field might be moving forward
in terms of next steps to really try to
leverage, you know, this methodology to
better understand emotional behavior.
Yeah.
So I think there's a number of cool things
that are going on in the field right
now. The first one is, um,
this idea of I'm mechanism or process and
I think that's where emotion really is
an important domain to start, is to
start looking at process. So, um,
one domain we've looked at is the brain.
Of course,
we know that hormones like testosterone
and cortisol cross the blood brain
barrier and bind to receptors
and influence, um, uh,
activity in the brain. Uh, but we also
know that there's, uh, an experience,
a psychological process that is going on,
um,
that might trap with what's
going on in the brain of course,
but that needs to be
studied independently.
And I think that's really an exciting
new direction, uh, that we're,
we're taking as a field is some
when your testosterone levels rise,
you know, how are you feeling? Um,
and similarly when your testosterone
levels drop or your cortisol called
cortisol levels rise as well. Um, so that,
that's one step is getting a mechanism
and process and I think emotion is going
to play a critical role in that.
Um, the other thing is, um, uh,
more about this idea of nuance.
And what I'll be a little bit more
specific about that is that I'm,
there seem to be contextual cues that
effect when hormones such as testosterone
or cortisol are released in a
predictable way. So, for example,
we know that, um, when we
threatened people status,
that's really when testosterone,
Roland social behaviors strong,
but under normal conditions when
status threat isn't really relevant,
we're not getting a profound effect.
So kind of understanding these
context depending, qs is really,
really an important critical next
step that we're taking as a field.
And the other thing is not just context
dependence but person dependent.
So how do you see yourself?
What's your personality like and how
does hormones such as testosterone
influence say someone who sees themselves
as really dominant person versus
someone who doesn't?
And what we're seeing is
really drastically different
effects depending on these
kinds of self perceived,
um, personality processes.
So I think there's just a lot more
to do in terms of mechanism and uh,
and nuance. And that's kind
of where the field is heading,
is debunking kind of these age old
myths about just these simple views and
really trying to understand
them in a more systematic way.
And I think emotion research is in
a play a important role in this new
resurgence of research on
hormones and social behavior. So
well, it's exciting to have you
here at the forefront, you know,
leading this work at probing mechanism,
steeply, understanding the nuances. And,
and related to this, I mean, I think about
how you've already started to do this,
you know,
with your dual hormone hypothesis where
you really examine really carefully this
interrelationship between cortisol on the
one hand and testosterone on the other,
you know,
predicting a wide range of behaviors
already from social status to decision
making. And I wonder if you
could just tell us a bit more,
what do you see as some of the
most exciting discovery so far?
Yeah, sure. I'd be happy to share
that. So, um, as I sort of mentioned,
we've sort of had this view that cortisol
is the stress hormone and testosterone
is the dominance hormone.
And for the past a hundred years,
both in humans and animal work,
it's been these systems that have been
studied pretty much independently.
So you'll see long tradition of research
on Cortisol's role in social behavior
and you'll see a similar parallel
line of work on testosterone,
swollen social behavior. But if you look
deeply and critically at the literature,
what you'll find is a lot of mess.
So you'll see Messi findings at sometimes
see a fax and sometimes you won't, um,
across really similar behaviors such as,
um,
stress related processes or motions or,
or decisions like you're saying.
And so what we wondered based on some,
um,
biology evidence is one of these
two systems could interact that is,
might the influence of testosterone on
behavior depend on whether someone is low
or high in cortisol.
And what we're seeing in now
about 10 studies is this,
this seems to be the case in a
number of different domains. Um,
so for example, someone high in
testosterone and low cortisol, uh,
they tend to have a more
challenge response to threats. Um,
they tend to have a more approach
oriented and resilience style.
So dealing with a threat
in the environment,
whereas someone high in
testosterone and high in cortisol,
they seem to have a more negative effect
or distress related response to these
kinds of threatening situation.
So we're,
we're really trying to
understand these profiles,
not just understanding one hormone,
uh, independent of other homo system,
but these profiles,
uh,
specifically in this case testosterone
and cortisol and we're finding is some
counterintuitive new new directions
for the field of social VR.
Um, specific to, um, the
study of emotion is, um,
an interesting finding related to train
anxiety or trait neuroticism in that is
that people high in testosterone and low
cortisol, they tend to have a more calm,
cool, uh, style, uh,
with dealing with stressors in the worlds.
And this actually makes them perform
better in positions of leadership is what
we're finding.
So I just saw some low cortisol
people are low in trait anxiety.
In contrast,
people,
high testosterone in high in cortisol
seems to be really high in trading side.
And like I said, they have
threat related responses, uh, uh,
to stressors in the environment and
they tend to not make as good leaders.
And we think it's because of this,
um,
these feelings of anxiety and
distress that they're feeling.
So I think that's one segue into how
this kind of dual common approach might,
um, might provide insights into
emotion research in particular.
It's really cool to hear how you're
mapping these profiles onto domains
relevance to aspect as well as clinically
relevant kind of emotion profiles are
talking about anxiety and neuroticism.
So it's just,
it's wonderful to see this work happening.
So I think like you're hinting at,
it's going to yield so many important
discoveries in the years to come.
Yeah,
I think so as well.
So it's specific to your point about
clinical utility that's an exciting new
direction that, um, that we're
hoping to take in the next few years.
So specifically, like you said, it's
hinting at that, um, for, for example,
we know that neuroticism is
a, is a predictor of, uh,
aspect of disorders,
clinical aspect of disorders.
And so we just have some of
the first evidence of that. Um,
but we need to do a lot more work so
we know that I'm studying emotional
experience in the real world.
So these were just one time
measures of emotional experience,
but really studying and mapping these
hormone processes on to real world
emotional experiences and important on
direction for future work. And really, um,
some of the studies that I've
talked to you about emotion,
we really looked at just a little
snapshot of the Neuro neuroendocrine
specifically looking at maybe one sample,
um,
to provide a window into
how the system works.
But we know that the system is a
lot more complex. Specifically,
we know that there's, um, diurnal curve,
so cortisol and testosterone are highest
in the morning drop throughout the day.
Um, and so understanding the slopes and
shapes of these curves are going to be an
important and exciting way to go
specifically in the land of emotion.
Excellent. Well, my final question about
your work really touches on, you know,
the ways in which you're exploring just
innovative approaches to utilizing tools
of neuroendocrinology to inform and
enhance our understanding of psychological
disorders, which you just hinted that
including mood disorders. And I wonder,
you know, we've just talked
about this clinical application,
but do you think that there's
some division of, um, you know,
the potential clinical utility that
these methods might bear for maybe
understanding emotional
disorders that you've alluded to,
but maybe even more accurately
detecting them or treating them?
Do we think this might be a possible
translational approach as we move forward?
I definitely think so. June. Um,
I just think we need to do the basic
science to understand what we're trying to
predict. So, um, so I absolutely think
that this type of clinical application,
so like I said, if, if we're finding
that there's a specific profile, um,
neuroendocrine profile that's
associated with risk factors for a,
a social anxiety disorder,
um, uh, clinical depression,
it would be really important obviously
for clinicians to know this information.
Uh, I think the first step is we really
have to be kind of confident that this is
what's going on. And, um,
like you said, we need,
we need rich or methods for studying,
uh, the neuroendocrine system. So,
um, for example, uh, we've
of course brought people
into the lab, are really, uh,
tracking people and their daily lives is
one important domain. Uh, another, uh,
important way to study the
neuroendocrine system is, um,
by giving people hormones are changing
their hormone system to exoticness
administration. So we're
working on studies, uh,
where we give people
testosterone for example.
So you might've seen commercials
on Androgel, um, that come on.
And really this is a, a, uh,
a way for researchers to sort
of study the causal processes.
So the causal links between hormones
and emotion. Um, and so yeah,
I think there's a lot of exciting,
uh, new directions that people can go.
And I think ultimately there,
these will have translational
and clinical applications.
So,
I mean,
you've really nicely alluded to like
where you see the future of the field
headed, which sounds really exciting.
And I wonder, as part of this, you know,
when you have students come to you and
ask you for advice or they're thinking
about embarking in this domain,
what advice do you give them when you
think about their future and where the
future of the field is headed?
That's a great question. I think, um,
one of the privileges of being in a really
young field is that there's a lot of
questions that are in some
ways low hanging fruits for
students because they'll
have this idea, they're interested in the
topic, let's say race bias and emotion,
um, or prejudice. And
so for example, in my,
one of my student's job is
interested in this topic,
but if you look at the research on this,
there's no work really that's looked at
the neuroendocrine processes that might
be related.
Um,
and so I think at least for
students right now in the field, um,
I think just sort of going
with what your passion is,
what the psychological question is and um,
and it seems to be the case that for a
lot of these questions there just hasn't
been the work done to study the hormones.
So that's one thing.
But even in the cases where there are,
I think just thinking about things in
a slightly different way or approaching
the question in a slightly different
way is going to be the key to sort of
contributing to the
bigger science process.
There's a number of ways you can do this.
Sometimes we just kind of
combine different ideas from
different fields and this
can be a new way.
Sometimes we have a new method that we
approached the question with. So I think,
um, I think this is a great time for
students to get involved in social
neuroendocrinology work
just because it's so young.
Well, thank you so much for speaking
today. Primes. It was wonderful,
and your insights are just very
inspiring and really opened up a lot of
questions for this newly emerging field.
You know that I see you
as at the forefront of
thanks so much for having me.
It was a great, great time.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with doctor [inaudible] Mehta
from the University of Oregon.
Thanks.